le gouvernement a donc annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'il augmentait de 12
milliards 37 milliards au total son aide
au remboursement de la dette de la sncf
contre un effort de productivité
donnant-donnant chantage ont répondu les
syndicats le gouvernement a ajouté qu'il
n'entendait pas remettre en cause de
régimes de retraite spécifique des
cheminots et ce soir la négociation a
repris pascal golomer jacques dernier
attention une table ronde peut en cacher
une autre n'a pas être allé hier chez
jacques barrot les syndicats de
cheminots on retrouve ce soir leur
président jean bergougnoux cette fois
pour parler en détails du contrat de
plan on le sait depuis ce matin né à
reprendre à l'année prochaine 37 des 175
milliards de francs de dette de la sncf
sans contrepartie
pour le reste tout dépendra des
résultats de l'entreprise et donc des
efforts des cheminots en matière
salariale notamment si les résultats
s'améliorent
la dette sera allégée ce sera francs
pour francs donnant-donnant chantage
dénoncé syndicats le donnant donnant et
fossés d'entrer dans la mesure où c'est
la dette de l'état que sncf supporte
c'est pas la peine des cheminots n'est
ni les usagers c'est l'actionnaire
unique état qui n'a pas participé à ces
investissements dans le mode ferroviaire
c'est donc à lui de trouver les moyens
pour assumer ses responsabilités
malheurs après coup ce plan que rejette
la cgt la cfdt c'est pour jean
bergougnoux le plan de la dernière
chance
encore faut-il convaincre des cheminots
lancer dans le conflit le plus dur
depuis 1986
pascal